and then part b show that when t is
greater than three
uh x is e given by and so we now have
this different displacement model
kicking in you see i sort of wrote down
where is it right here this is the
displacement model
that works for the first three seconds
but it gets replaced by this
dramatically
more complicated uh displacement model
because i now have to take into effect
not just this
constant frictional force but also this
reverse
thrust which is proportional to the
square of the velocity this is our
sort of resistive motion type situation
so this is going to be
my destination this is where i want to
go so how do i get there
well i'm going to go back and write down
let's see here
part b i'm going to go back to the idea
of saying when i defined
from naught to 3 right here when i
defined my
my force equation here that just came
from you can see just on this left hand
side
there's the constant frictional force
and that's it right but now i can
have in addition to this the reverse
thrust so in addition to
minus 2m i'm also going to have minus
1 over 10 000 mv squared so the mass is
there as another constant
and it's also slowing me down it's also
a retarding force so it will also
be negative so i'm going to make a very
similar argument to what i did here
except
in addition to this minus 2m there will
also be this
minus 1 over ten thousand mv squared
okay so let's write that down
four oops it is e4t is greater than
three what am i going to get well i'll
have
the force which is mass times
acceleration
that's going to be we've got the
constant frictional force there from the
brakes
and then we also have the minus uh 1
over 10 000 m
v squared and that comes from the
reverse thrust so just like i did before
i'm going to divide both sides
by the mass and that gives me an
acceleration equation
minus 2 minus i'm going to pop that v
squared up on the numerator
like so okay now this is good
um i've made some progress i've got you
know this is this is gonna be true for t
is greater than three
um whereas my previous model sort of
stops between zero and three because
that's the only place where the brakes
are going and now i look at what i'm
trying to get to right
x equals and then i have all of these
numbers in here
now some of this i hope looks familiar
for example the 207 is clearly going to
come from this displacement that we got
in the previous part part a
that 66 is also going to come from this
velocity equals 66 so we're going to
substitute that in
shortly but we're not there yet right
what i need here if i have a look
closely at this equation
it's a displacement equation in terms of
velocity there's there's no more
no more time right did you notice in
part a we were looking at you know our
equations for velocity and displacement
were all time equations so we integrated
with respect to t
but here time seems to have disappeared
um well this is a
model that's not in terms of time so
therefore i need to think about
just like i did at this point here you
can see i said i'm going to integrate
with respect to t
so i was thinking of this really as dv
on dt that's what i was really doing but
is dv and dt going to be the most
useful um expression for acceleration
that will help me get to here and the
answer is of course not because it's
on dt so it would be in terms of t if i
did any integration with it
i need something which is in terms of
velocity there's the um there's the
variable there so
which of the forms is going to be most
useful to me maybe you're already
working it out you've sort of planned
out in your head
the most helpful form if i want to get
displacement
in terms of which is x in terms of
velocity
is going to be v dv on dx
this is acceleration in terms of
velocity and then i have everything
over here on the right hand side
unchanged
okay now as we've done before what i
want to do now is i just want to kind of
separate out my variables my
v's and my x's and then i'm just going
to integrate as in as straightforward
away as i can
so you can see over on the left hand
side i've got this extra v
there so i'm going to deal with that by
dividing everything through by
v that gives me minus 2 on v minus
v on 10 000
and then from here what i want to do is
get everything on the right hand side
into
a single expression because i'm going to
need to divide it through
onto the other side with the dv and that
dx on the left hand side is going to go
on to the right hand side
okay so let me see if i can get this
straight i still got dv on dx
on the left hand side and then when i
put these two fractions together
and get a common denominator number one
i'm just going to take that minus sign
out the front because it's a common
factor and i'm going to be on top of 10
000
v so therefore it looks to me like i'm
going to get 20 000
multiplying through by 10 000 and then
i'm going to get a v
squared on the right because i'm
multiplying through by v
so all of that is divided through by 10
000 v make sure i've got the right
number of zeros there
okay from here as promised i'm going to
do my separation of variables because
i've just got everything nice and neat
as a fraction so i'm going to
divide through by this or multiply by
its reciprocal so what does that leave
me with i'm going to have 10
000 v on uh
20 000 plus v squared and then the dv
i'm happy to leave on the left hand side
because everything is in terms of v over
there
and then i've still got this minus sign
and i'm multiplying through by
dx i know this is a little bit sneaky
because
you can see what i'm doing is i'm
treating the dv and the x just like a
regular fraction
in this context i can but you need to
remember there's actually a limiting
process
going on underneath here just like there
is in chain rule so you have to be
mindful of the fact that this trick
doesn't always work but in this context
with sort of like related rates of
change it is totally fine
okay now just before i go through and
integrate everything you might notice
over here on the left hand side
you've got something where you've got a
v function at the top and v squared
function down the bottom
this is going to integrate up into a log
but there's one more thing i can do to
make this a bit easier for myself
which is to try and get the numerator
looking exactly like the derivative of
the
denominator getting that f dash on f
situation that we've seen so many times
before
now if this is f if that f of v is the
denominator
then f dash v is just going to be well
don't worry about the 20 000 it's a
constant differentiates away
this v squared should differentiate into
2v
now thankfully i don't have to do that
much to turn this into 2v i just have to
take out a factor that's appropriate
in this case it's 5 000. so i'm going to
go ahead and write that here in this
step if i leave that as a 2 and then i'm
going to put the 5000
out the front like so now i am ready
to integrate and so that 5000 um doesn't
need to be part of the
of the integration process so i'm going
to move that over there i'll integrate
here
and then i'll integrate here so you can
see i am now set up and ready to go
what am i going to get well left-hand
side gives me something i was hoping for
you've got the 5000
then there's the log of 20 000 plus
v squared before i even touch the right
hand side i'm just going to go back to
the question
and you can see number one we've got the
5000 number two we've got the log
number three we've got this 20 000 plus
v squared very very
promising okay that's good what am i
going to get
with the rest of this well that looks
like it's going to be minus
x plus g what constant am i up to um i
got up to constant 2 up there so it
looks like i'm going to be up to
constant
3 now so more integrals then you can
shake
a stick out okay constant 3 is there
now what i want to do is try and get
this in a form that makes it easy for me
to work out
number one displacement as a function of
velocity because that was the whole
point of the question and number two
i also need to evaluate this constant so
i'm just going to add x
to both sides and then i'm going to
leave that c3 over there
and then i'm going to subtract this
awkward log term that you can see over
here on the left hand side
i'm going to subtract that from both
sides and there we go
now what have i got at this point well
i know that this situation starts from
after t in fact i should really say that
includes
well it sort of includes three because
that's when the breaks come sorry the
reverse thrust comes in but
the question didn't include the boundary
but that's i think okay
i know what happens at time three my
initial condition
even though it's time three initial
condition for when the reverse thrust
first kicks in so i'm going to say uh
when t equals three i've got those
values
for x and v that i determined in part
a so that was x equals 207
and my velocity was 66. we already knew
we were going to have to substitute
these in
just by looking at what the question for
part b what the model looked like
so therefore let me go and do the
substitution i get let's say
207 on the left hand side um c3 is what
i'm trying to evaluate and then
minus 5 000 log and then does this look
familiar
20 000 plus 66.
squared there's a subtraction there so
you can see
oops let's go right back to the question
there's that 20 000 plus 66 squared
which has emerged
and it's also tucked inside this 5000
log
etc okay so therefore from here i'm just
going to add that awkward
log term to both sides it's 207
plus everything you can see here
okay excellent so now i'm going to do is
i'm going to back substitute
constant 3 back into this expression or
this equation rather for
displacement and then i'm pretty much
there right x
equals c 3 which we've just determined
is this constant
so it's that and then you're going to
subtract
this term over here which is what we got
from the original integration
so that's equal to 207
uh plus and then you can see there's
this 5000
which is a common factor from here and
here and then you've got
these logs being subtracted see there's
a subtraction there subtract this log
from oh sorry subtract this log from
that log but if you think back to your
logarithm laws
when you subtract logs which have the
same base and in this case
it's base e you can divide the two
things inside the log so therefore
i get the log here and then as was
required by the question
here's the 20 000 plus 66 squared and
then there's the 20 000
plus the v squared and there you have it
x on the left hand side displacement as
a function of
velocity and you can see the the 207 in
exactly the right spot
and or the rest of it okay
as required